Jeff starts us off in Ann Arbor Michigan
hi Jeff welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave thank you so much for taking my
call
sure what's up in your world so I have a
unique question about student loan debt
and buying a house my wife and I have a
little over $400,000 in student loan
debt
um she is a doctor and I am graduating
from law school and I have a job lined
up and we will be moving we had planned
on renting to please next year and just
really throwing all of our money at
student waters well you should you have
a you have a disaster on your hands yeah
you you must you must live in a tent I
mean really we should next year growth
about five hundred and fifteen thousand
right pay your student loan debt off
okay um I guess the reason I was calling
is we they just drop the price on our
dream house honey you just got out of
Law School you can't have a dream house
yet your four hundred twenty thousand
dollars in loan in student loans you can
only have a dream house after that's
paid for I mean there's lots of houses
and you can dream again if you make five
hundred fifty thousand dollars a year
and your debt free for three years go
build your dadgum Dream House okay but
don't don't don't play games with this
don't don't
I mean please good lord this I mean you
got a great big shovel but dude you're
holed I mean half of America just about
drove off the road when you told me your
student loan them out you really I mean
it's a big hole why don't you have
gotten used to it because you're running
around with a bunch of doctors and
lawyers students but and so you've
you've become but you need to understand
that you're in the top one tenth of one
percent of stupid land on student loans
you really have got to get this cleaned
up and you can't play with it it's not
something you have a grenade in each
hand and the pin has been pulled please
get rid of the bomb okay that answers my
question thank you so much Dave thank
you sir how many people think he's going
to do that you think he's going to do
I think he's gonna buy the house I don't
think that well well that's okay it's
okay yeah that's why I'm here
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind